For the first one we'll get 1 plus 11i, and for the second one we'll get 3 plus
5i. Great effort if you found those two answers. For the sum we can drop the
parentheses since we're not multiplying anything. Then we just add the real
numbers together to get 4 minus 3 which equals 1. For the imaginary numbers we
have 6i and 5i, and that sums to 11i. Don't make the mistake of adding these
two together to get 12i. Remember this i represents the square root of negative
1 so these are not like terms. This is a real number and this is an imaginary
number. When we subtract this complex number we want to distribute this
negative 1 to each term this means positive 4 becomes negative 4 and negative
2i becomes positive 2i. Now, we're ready to add our real numbers together and
our imaginary numbers together. We'll have 7 minus 4, which equals 3, and 3i
plus 2i, which equals 5i. This gives us our final result of 3 plus 5i. Well
done.